welcome back this is national police
week it comes as policing is now a hot
topic in washington and maybe on your
kitchen table
with parties on both sides pushing for
reform but
is anyone asking law enforcement what
would make their jobs more effective
make it easier better
before reform is thrust upon them from
washington
so we did with an exclusive look at the
methods in the midst behind policing in
2021
from the lens of the actual officers you
know the first responders that you see
the bad guys who save lives you know
they get stabbed sometimes they get shot
sometimes and even
deliver babies before an ambulance
arrives like these officers did in
nassau county new york just a few days
ago
here is their perspective every time i
pull somebody over you don't know what
you've been walking up against
[Music]
may i see a license registration
insurance please
i cannot see who i'm pulling over until
i actually walk up onto the
side of their window
that could be wanted for murder could
have guns in the car
[Music]
in these road conditions with the rain
we'd like to see you go a little slower
all right thank you so much have a good
day
he was cooperative he was cordial he
understood everything i was saying
and um you know i just decided to give
him a warning that goes a long way right
oh yeah attitude is everything courtesy
is contagious
commissioner police officers often say
the most dangerous thing they do is a
car stop
there is no such thing as a routine cost
stop and you've heard it around the
country they want to have unarmed car
stops that are conducted with social
workers with social workers
this is the most dangerous job whether
it's the traffic that's driving by you
or whether it's the individual inside
that car the person you're going to
encounter on the street
this call that we're going to handle now
is going to simulate it by two officers
standing behind
doors of a police car the call comes out
for a suspicious male
he attempt to be burglarized in a house
and he may have a weapon on him
when you saw the gun they have the
training says fire absolutely
sometimes they could have something else
in their hand they're trained to look
for a weapon
right you term with a weapon whether
it's a fake weapon or a real weapon
there's a good chance you're going to
get shot we train to stop
threats we don't shoot to kill as i've
heard too many times on tv
in this scenario the officers handled it
perfectly right uh so
this is the story at two in the
afternoon can you give me the same
scenario
at two in the morning we can do that
give them the lights
that's the county police stop sir that's
the county please stop get on the ground
that's about so much tougher at night
yeah the environment changes when the
environment changes it's dark
you don't get to see that weapon just as
fast
in this scenario that you're going to
see the individual's got a knife
we have distance we have time we have
control that we were able to pull the
taser out
many times the taser don't work if both
prongs don't hit it does not run the
current through them
to stun the person sir you've been asked
several times to drop the knife drop the
knife oh
taser taser taser
[Music]
so what you've seen and you see how fast
he's able to get back up
that taser we can press the taser again
and send more current back into it how
do you feel now
i feel great now i mean i could have
ranted him full with him keep fighting
with these guys
i lost complete control of my left leg
so often you hear about we don't want to
see military equipment and surplus
equipment
on the street it gives the wrong message
to the communities
i look at this vehicle and although it's
built for a different cause
it looks like something that might be
under scrutiny from washington
when they talk about police
this is a what we call a bearcat we
purchased this
this is like a bulletproof ambulance it
can bring my men
safely men and women safely into an
environment of an active shooter
and they take those victims out from
that same environment
you just had something where you needed
this vehicle at the stopping shop that
made national news you're able to bring
a suspect
in alive
that vehicle was on the scene in front
if the individuals started to shoot from
the window
and hit somebody this vehicle is going
to get them out safely
it's not used often but when it's needed
it's there for us
as we see this cell phone video and we
see this uh the body camera video
what is it like guys on the street like
that as we see scenarios where you're
wrestling around
and non-compliant suspects it's a
challenging time policing right now
you want to do your job out there and
get the bad guy off the street but the
same time as you said
everyone's videotaping it and monday
morning quarterbacking is something that
is almost deterring us from
deploying the different moves and
techniques that we've been taught
if qualified to community disappear
tomorrow you now have to wonder will you
have a home to go to
at the end of the week or are we going
to be losing our homes and losing
everything that we have and everything
we build up
it's a challenging time it really is
because we all took the job to do the
right thing and that's to help the
community
and now once everyone's watching it on
the news it's
making a second guess every decision you
make
[Music]
special thanks to nassau county police
especially their version of swat for
lebanon helping us out give us an
understanding how hard they train to
make sure everything comes out right
and sometimes you do everything right
and it comes out wrong and we see a lot
of that joining us now a man who knows
all this
he's been studying this uh hot and heavy
for over a year republican senator from
south carolina tim scott
senator want to give people a
perspective from the police officer
we know you're talking about police
reform what should they know about what
you're working on
well brian first thing we should say is
uh thank god for people who put on the
uniform this is national police week so
there's no better time for us to say
thank you to an officer
so when you see an officer around your
neighborhoods around the streets
please stop and say thank you to those
officers two of my brothers from another
mother my mentor's
kids both are deputies and so it's
really important for us to take that
time
what they should know about what we're
doing in congress is
taking first in into consideration the
important work that they do
and making sure that we keep our
officers safe if you want communities to
be safe
you have to have officers who are not
thinking about their personal liability
or their assets
as they run into harm's way that is one
of the reasons why for qualified
immunity
i am i have been for the last year open
for putting more of the onus on the
municipalities
on the counties on the state and taking
it off of
the officers that to me is the way that
we continue to tell
the officers that we need them going
into harm's way
without having to have an additional
level of exposure from a liability
perspective
senator carm's going through the roof
all across the country and academies are
emptying
out and their people are retiring
rapidly you're going to see a massive
exodus
in june here because of the overtime
they try to leave with the most overtime
to retire with the most money
on may 25th the democrats said they want
to see something
some of the things that you talk to me
about qualified immunity you talk about
suing the precinct not the person
you talk about the no knock warrants and
you talk about the no chokeholds what
else should police officers
and the citizens think that you're going
to know that you're going to be talking
about
with democrats well you mentioned two
other issues number one
one that is really important is that
section 242 which is making it easier
they're looking to lower that threshold
i said that as a no go for me section
242
is a criminal element in employees
reform i am not interested in that
whatsoever
the other one is what you just mentioned
about having the right equipment that
section 1033
is the military equipment that can go to
police offices
i think it's important for us having run
a county with a sheriff's department
myself
previously it's really important for us
to make sure they have the tools
necessary
there's a list that's already been
banned and re-establishing that same
list is fine with me but
having that mrap or those uh pieces of
equipment or vehicles that bring
officers safely
into harm's way to get them and the
other innocent folks out of harm's way
is something that i i completely support
and will continue to support so
those are really the top five issues you
just named them
that we're working on and then the
devil's in the detail we need to read
every line every letter every word
to make sure that there's not something
sneaking in the back door i'd rather
have no deal than a bad deal
i hear you two things training smaller
stations
small precincts don't have the money and
they got to pay them more
if you want federal money help on both
those things number two when people say
defund the police and we know this
democrats and the squad members keep
saying it reimagining getting rid of the
they're they're uh irreconcilable what
are you going to do about that
sentiment center can you deal with that
well
the way i deal with defund the police is
the dumbest thing i've ever heard in my
whole life um having lived in
singaporean household in poverty
we always want police officers around
when necessary
to especially to keep our moms safe so
that's really important so
that is off the table from my opinion
and we need to provide
more resources more money bottom line
when i say resources i mean money
coming into especially our smaller
departments and even our mid-size
department so that the training
to intervene and the training on
de-escalation
all those uh training dollars are
incredibly important
we don't need less money for the police
we need more keep your eye on this i
know you're used to
nothing getting done in washington but
senator tim scott's different and
i think if anyone can do it you can do
it senator thanks so much
thanks have a good day all right uh hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox you can get it all here
on youtube so subscribe right now